Summer's here and you know what that means.
The sun's out and it's time to show everyone what you're all
about.
Hags Hat, a new joint venture from MataraCon and then
Phantom.
The Hags Hat for people who just love the classics.
Turbo, breathable mesh sides, varsity fonts so people think
you're educated.
Sturdy built to protect your sensitive little eyes and
adjustable sizing.
Hags Hat, we live in complicated times and it can be hard to
express who you are, what you value, what you're looking for
in a summer, in a companion, in life.
Hags hat!
The hat does it all tastefully, legally, and with full
deniability.
But wait, there's more!
Order one haggs hat, and you will receive one haggs hat at
full standard cost.
Order two, and you will receive two haggs hats for you and a
friend, or two for you to wear on top of each other.
Order a third haggs hat, and that's right, you guessed it,
you will receive three haggs hats.
Disclaimer, one size fits all claim based on human
proportions, sizing not guaranteed for various animalian
extraterrestrial heads.
City of the Yard bill cannot protect eyes when looking
directly into the sun.
Matar Khan and Mid-Pantom cannot be held liable if your
summer is bad boring or otherwise not great this hat cannot
replace a degree from an accredited university purchase
multiple hats has no impact on greatness of summer hag not
included hello everybody and welcome back to in an hour's
welcome back to in an hour's time with matara con today i
got the one the only dokey bird with me she's got a
contagious laugh there she is and a lethal aiming skill
thank you for joining me you for inviting me matara yippee
we we are here right before you know anime expo having fun
and i know it's super tight the timing so i really really
appreciate you joining me tonight i'm happy to be here this
is my second podcast ever yeah wow what was the first one
was it really pichu uh for her oh that's awesome channel
yeah that's really cool what was it the one where you draw
no no it was the one where um it was like it's just us
talking i think they like retired oh that's awesome the
podcast channel i don't remember what it was called okay so
this is your first currently currently on air podcast yeah
it was a sweet and sour podcast yeah oh yeah yeah oh that's
awesome that's really cool um but also for later we are
gonna have probably one or two drinks on the patreon i'm
gonna get wasted matara up here pressured me to drink i am i
am but you know what i had so much fun drinking with you
last time run it again run it back you know we gotta run it
back we gotta run it back girl drunken dokey talk and the
patreon remember that subscribe to patreon guys drunk dokey
drunk dokey is quite something else i i'm trying to remember
what little tidbit was you told me about pandas and they're
that pandas need to be shown porn in order to have sex
because they're like very i want to i found out one of the
reasons why they don't they don't just bang is that they're
very they have like types and stuff some pandas have
specific types and they're like that's not my we talked
about this that's what we talked about i was like well what
if they're showing them the wrong pornography right what if
it's like i i just imagine my editor sweating we're just at
the beginning but imagine they're showing them the wrong
pornography like what if these two pandas want like
something different and they're showing them they're like i
don't like that that's all my type of stuff won't biracial
because they're black and white oh my god maybe all right
after this lovely intro that's what you're gonna get on
patreon guys that's sober dokey that's that's can you tell
the listeners a little bit about yourself something that
they might not know something you know tell us a little bit
about you it's always hard to explain yourself you know like
introduce yourself i'm always so jealous people they have
this like long ass intro and i'm just like i'm toky bird
guys hey i was i was reading one of your one of your things
on your website it was like oh yeah i didn't write that i'm
i'm i'm the laughing i almost said i almost said another
thing i'm i'm laughing and you know i i like to bully not
bully people it was like i'm i'm likely to tease yeah what
do i just read off of my wikipedia my what was it called the
vtuberpedia or whatever go to dokeymerch.com and read off my
the fandom virtual youtuber okay it's dokey has an energetic
trickster type personality she loves to laugh and they make
other people laugh dokey enjoys messing with people is more
likely to taunt others rather than brag about
guys that was on your website not written by me by i didn't
write this she's especially well known for high skilled
level and apex legends and overwatch yeah guys you know i
got top 500 and apex overwatch and marvel rivals um let's go
i don't brag about myself or anything uh no no she's very
humble she's humble as she's so humble girl if i was top 500
and anything you'd never hear me Exactly.
See, I don't mention that at all.
Anyway, I have so many top 500s in so many.
In so many.
Look at all.
You're like Tom Bradley.
You're like you're just showing up after the Super Bowl with
all your rings, you know?
Oh, man.
Sorry, I just won the Super Bowl.
So I didn't have enough time to change or anything.
You look at all my rings.
Oh, where should I put all 700 rings that's on my hand right
now?
Oh, my awards are so heavy.
Oh my god, these metals, they're weighing, my back hurts
from the metals.
It's so hard to be me right now, Tom Brady.
Oh, I don't know how I do it, you know.
Keep reading though, this is great.
This is great.
No, while she often comes off as loud and chaotic, Doki also
has a cute, wholesome side that becomes especially
noticeable when drawing or making bentos and has gained a
reputation for Gap Moe.
She's very hardworking and often goes to great lengths to
say it.
her fellow vtubers actually um we are recording this right
after you were watching the mexico i'm an i am representing
mexican i wanted to ask you so you you tweeted something the
other day about becoming an honorary mexican you went to a
restaurant and you just became an honorary mexican what's up
with that um basically what happened was that it was post um
it was post Canada versus Switzerland and I was there at the
I traveled there to the arena and so obviously I was like
the arena BC place is right next to downtown so I went to
downtown I kept walking until like the red shirts started
disappearing uh because I because obviously there's gonna be
so many people eat like eating right post post games I
wanted to find a restaurant that had like where it was like
obviously there was like room for me to go to eat because I
was I kept walking like I walked like 15 minutes down the
street until there were other shirt colors and then I went
in the restaurant it was a good restaurant too but it's not
like it was like a shitty it was a good restaurant and I
didn't I didn't notice this but I went in and I realized
everyone around me when they're like I sat down and everyone
around me had this green shot glass drink and I was like I
don't want that like what's everyone drinking like why does
everyone else have I want to drink what everybody else yeah
of course so I asked the waiter I was like what are drinking
can i also order one and then the waiter was like you can't
have it i was like why i was like did he think you were a
child they're like they're like you can't sorry you can't
have it it's like not for you and i'm like what do you mean
not for me like i i didn't understand i was like everyone
else has it like yeah what do you mean not for me and then i
found out um i was the only non-mexican in the restaurant it
wasn't by the way it wasn't even a mexican restaurant It was
a Japanese restaurant.
It was like...
So...
Vamos Snoopy!
So it was...
I didn't know at first because like I just wanted to be
like, I want sushi.
And then so I was the only non-Mexican person in this
restaurant.
And then I realized, oh wait, everyone around me is Mexican
because they're like, they're like, salute.
Like, you know, cheers with their...
Vamos Snoopy!
And I was like, oh, oh, it's they're all I'm the only not
that's why I'm not allowed because I'm not Mexican That's
why they won't give me that's a little that's a little
discriminatory, but I get it.
I get it So then this nice now I won't say old maybe she's
like in her 40s and 50s.
So she's like your age, you know, like this I'm at that age
where older men are just men.
So there's this nice mature lady came up to me and was like,
are you Mexican?
And I was like, no, I'm not Mexican.
And she's like, it's okay.
I will make you an honorary Mexican.
And then you're Mexican today.
And then she was like, because I was like, no, I just came
back from the Canada Swiss game.
And she's like, it's okay.
I'll make you an honorary Mexican for the day.
And she's like, Saloo everyone.
And everyone's like, Saloo!
Wait, how did she make you Mexican?
Did she like christen you?
you did you get to drink the green drink i still did it she
just what was the green okay you are an honorary mexican
today and i was just like and then they all cheered she was
like salute and then everyone was like salute and i was like
salute and then i was mexican okay day uh this is so funny i
fully believe you because i know how cities get during these
no no no i know how cities get during like no no but this
sounds like one of those like and then everybody claps you
know but i No, it's true because I know how cities get
during the sports.
Yeah, because like...
But it's funny, we're like, and then everybody cheered.
The Mexican game was like literally like a game, like one,
like two games after the Canada game.
So they were all like pre-gaming for the...
Pre-gaming.
Yeah, they're all pre-gaming.
What is the green dream?
I don't know.
I have to know.
Did your audience...
They never told me.
Did you explain it to you?
No, it was a shot glass.
It was a shot glass.
There was green in it.
And then like there was a Canada flag on top of it.
So I didn't know it was a, it was like Mexican theme because
they put a Canada flag on top of it.
Yeah.
I guess they didn't have them.
I'm so sorry.
The fact that they wouldn't let you have it is so funny.
It's like you're not, you're not one of them.
And I was just like, what do you mean?
I'm so like, I was like, it's not for you.
And I was like, what do you mean it's not for me?
Like, you know, I feel bad.
I wonder if they had like a little party.
Yeah.
Like maybe they like reserved part of the restaurant and
like they were allowed a little freebie.
something that like they paid for they're like no you can't
have i was just like what are they drinking or maybe they
thought i was just like what are you drinking can i order
one too and they're like we're not it's not for you like i
need to ask the listeners what do you all think was because
for it to be so green i'm thinking it has to be like
something with madori or something with like um there's like
green there's like a green minty syrup thing yeah it could
be a syrup he's he's crashing the podcast sorry guys oh i
can't hear him it's okay but that is so funny that i thought
the the whole point i genuinely thought that the story was
going to culminate to they christened you mexican and they
gave you degrees no they just went salute but not even and
then how does it feel though i mean i met you at a very
latina time in your life how do you feel it's funny though
it's funny because like i no more chinese time in your life
because uh um i also hey no sorry my dog my dogs wants to
crash the podcast but you love your dog anyway all right
he's just gonna keep barking i'm gonna keep going i don't
think we can stop i remember when you told me your dog like
learned your no he does so your dog knows when we started
before we started this podcast like he said nothing because
he knows we're not doing anything we're just hanging out and
then he's like work time hours he he fucking comes up he's
like it's Because he knows he can get a treat.
He does because he knows I can't stop.
Like he knows I need to keep going.
He does this too.
Like during the stream when I was watching the Mexico versus
Ecuador game, he would bark randomly.
And then the moment stream ended, he was like, sleep time.
It's like I'm going back to sleep.
He just knows.
He knows.
But yeah, what were you talking about before he interrupted?
We're talking how you're in a very Chinese, Latin American
time in your life at the moment.
I forgot what I want to say.
No.
They were mixing.
I also got distracted by the dog.
We were saying how they were mixing and you never know they
might be, it's okay.
In Russian we say if it's important, you'll remember before
the wedding day.
That's true.
And me when I was a kid, I was like, what if I can marry
tomorrow mom?
What if I never remember?
Oh no, and then when you try to remember it, it goes further
and further away.
And you're like, I can't, I can't, it's not coming back.
Tonight you'll be in bed and you'll be like, oh my god i
just remembered being in a chinese latina time in my life
the same you were talking though about the ecuador and
mexico game and how you were watching it oh does it feel
like yeah does your life feel different now that you're
mexican food's good the food's good you grew a mustache i
saw that on stream i became everyone's deal aren't you
supposed to be a Tia no I'm Tia got my got my beer got my
tacos got my sombrero oh you're saying it's sombrero you're
saying it all like sombrero I like that it's been really
cool though it's been really cool to see you to see watch
the games and like getting into it I remember what I want to
say but it was really funny when I came back from the Canada
Swiss game To do a recap.
I was doing a recap for everyone.
And they were like, oh, Mexico game is going right now.
I'm still going.
And there was literally, like, I think it was like 20
minutes of the game left.
Like 20, like 25 minutes.
I was trying to find like the stream, like trying to like
subscribe to Crave.
You know, Crave, like.
Yeah, yeah, cuz I was, you're like, I was trying to find the
stream legally and react to the stream legally by paying my
legal money.
I was trying, I didn't want to get caught by FIFA, cups i
was trying to find a legal stream so i had to dig up my
subscription to crave and resubscribe and everything and
then the moment i got all the work working i started
watching the game they scored you're the and i was and then
everyone was like what like what happened and then you told
them you're oh no because you had already tweeted about your
mexican story so like they knew they knew oh my god you need
i i'm telling you next time though when you watch the game
you need to get some kind of Snoopy merch because as Snoopy
is like the most Mexican thing you can wear it's great I'm
so happy was the most Mexican so basically Snoopy is so so
so popular there and they call him a Snoopy with an e a
Snoopy and I remember looking it up I think it's because
like either like one of the original cartoonists or
something like that is actually Mexican so it kind of became
one of those like national pride or maybe it was like a
voice So it became like a big symbol of pride and everybody.
I mean, who doesn't love Snoopy?
Yeah, of course.
Right.
He's so cute.
He's like a little, he's a little guy.
He's just a little guy, you know?
He's just a little guy and we love him.
You know, speaking of little guys doing big things, I wanted
to talk about some of your big projects.
Wow, me.
You've been cooking and that.
Okay, wait, what is this podcast coming out?
On the 10th.
Oh, okay.
Like, oh, okay, never mind.
why why why nothing nothing oh you can't tease something no
nothing when it comes out when it comes to come back to this
episode be like that's what she was talking about all right
all right there is something that is being there's something
i'm guessing anime expo there's something oh no there's
something because it can't be anime expo because that's
before it attends
because you said there's something happening on the 10th so
there might be something but like it's not announced when
this podcast comes out no no oh the podcast sorry the first
episode of the podcast comes out tomorrow yeah no but when i
meant this episode your episode is coming out on the yeah
exactly so of july it's not out yet i'm so confused i don't
understand i'm so i'm sitting here so the episode is coming
out on 10th right yes there is something coming out for me
that can't say yet because by the time this podcast comes
out that thing hasn't come out yet so when it and it still
won't be announced on the 10th either when it comes out when
it comes out come back to you will know what it is when it
comes out all right thank you i get it again you're actually
you're being so sweet you are engagement and I'm too stupid
to realize it everyone come back to this podcast episode and
be like that's what she was talking about okay I'm really
excited I hope it's something good because last time we had
this kind of thing the last time we collabed and drank a
little bit where you were going on a trip to Korea and then
you kind of were like hey guys if I die it's Matara's fault
because she she hired a sniper and I was like That's so
funny.
And then the whole time I'm like, please don't talk, please
don't sign.
This is gonna be so awkward.
She's like, oh, what if it happens?
What if I get shot by a sniper?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So now it's like, oh guys, when it comes out, you're gonna
know what it is.
And then everybody comes in and be like, I cannot believe
Doki robbed like the Grand National Bank and like all the
computers shut down.
And Matara, you knew it, you couldn't stop it.
Why didn't you stop it?
i had no idea you that was really confusing but i loved it
so uh at anime expo yeah you have a sold out concert yeah
yeah i'm really excited i'm really excited i'm really
excited too i feel like but well by the time the podcast
comes out we've already seen each other's dot con we have we
have oh my god ducky yeah it was incredible did you like my
concert it was so good i can't like those notes you were
hitting was incredible.
Actually, you mean it because I have an original song that
will be coming out at the concert.
Yeah, I know because I saw it.
It's kind of like a James Bond kind of theme.
Yeah, exactly.
You saw did you like it?
Yeah, I did.
Did you like how I danced during it?
Oh, I did.
Oh, guys, you know you could, you know how you could also
watch the concert right now?
We do have streaming tickets right now that I can check.
Yep.
Hashtag editors put that in.
Integrated ad.
Hashtag ad editors.
Can't skip.
in there is still pay-per-view tickets available where you
can watch my concert was on the second of july and there was
also the like dj night and hers was on the fourth of july
yeah hashtag integrated ad we're sponsoring our own podcast
yeah no i mean why not why not one of the reasons too that i
i wanted to have talks with my friends is because typically
vtubers you know this they are so bad at advertising
themselves.
No, I'm hashtag shill all the time.
No, you're great.
I love it.
You're even shilling for me to get comments and I was too
stupid to realize.
I'm hashtag ad all the time.
It'd be like my drag loads, it'd be like, yeah, skip ad,
skip ad.
I was like, yeah, skip ad, skip ad.
This is integrated.
I love it.
I honestly, it's good, but don't worry, don't worry.
We're gonna talk about a lot of your achievements.
Because even though, you know, you did say that you're
modest and you're humble and you're funny or anything i'm so
humble but i want you to brag i want to know because look
you had a cover song come out and it hit a million it was
crazy and you're like oh how funny and now you keep getting
offered a bunch of opportunities to dance like when she can
sing and perform tell me about that i was like wait i can
see i was like i can but no you know no one and i i don't
know i said it before with you but when i up when i did that
cover song i did in less than a month because i was like
what do i do for my anniversary so like one month left i was
just like what do i do i just like i like this song i'm just
gonna sing it because you know it's like a i think you it's
a classic song you know like it's like something you like
sing in the shower or something so i don't really need to
practice it because i've sang this song growing up so it's
like what it's like disney songs like you always sing these
songs growing up so it's not like you have to learn it or
anything it just comes in naturally so I was just like I
don't have to learn it I'm just I'm just gonna rip it and
the thing is when I first got the the video like when I
first got a video and the song I didn't I don't want to say
I I it wasn't like I didn't like it but I thought it was
average personally I I was like really worried because I
thought I thought it was I think it's hard sometimes with
these kinds of videos right we're like oh could the video be
better could this be better yeah yeah because I was like I
don't know if I'm saying that well and then like I upload it
and it blew the fuck up and I was like this i was very
surprised i was like oh it was it's already at 1.4 million
that's awesome i think that's like the highest for like a
song i've done ever went so i was like wow no i really
really like the video i think it's really well done and i
get when it's your own video where you can not like it yeah
i also love when you sing a lot of times you do a cuter
voice oh yeah no no you kind
the song itself it's like more bratty in a way so it's like
i tried to like play it up because you're like hey i don't
like your girlfriend like you know yeah because it's like um
you could settle you know i could be your girlfriend you
know like yeah it's like break up with her when is um break
up with her and yeah when is your next cover coming out
because this was four months ago and you cooked and are you
getting invited to sing and dance and perform when's the
next one could be tomorrow could be next month it could be
the month after that who knows come on come on it just comes
and goes it just comes and goes what i i also saw that you
had a concert with my last week's guest ah mint that was a
while ago that was a while ago our first a big concert i
think like i i yeah so i think it definitely it was crazy
like it was crazy i like it was a crazy experience because
we both haven't done something like this before um even back
then not i know i know you're being humble but i need you to
understand i don't think something like that had been done
before previously a lot of these concerts were either
adjacent like at a convention or it was big corpo and this
was two independent youtubers having a concert it is
something that i i need you both to kind of like get your
flowers here you both did something and now people are
continuously doing concerts are a lot more popular now for
sure like a lot it's very accessible to like the indie
sphere now like you just get concerts like every month or
something too whether it's like online on stream or like at
a venue it's it's like there's so many um i think like i
think that's what i worry about so too because it's like
concert fatigue at some point yeah like traveling i think
like but i do want to see more concerts outside of the
united states um like maybe like in canada or something
because uh there's like canada also like we're both canadian
for anybody who doesn't know you americans out there your
currency is very strong in canada so please help our economy
yeah come to canada spend your money i would love to see as
well.
Yeah, that too.
Yeah.
Even though the euro is very strong.
I would love to see more in Europe.
So maybe Canada, we call dibs.
We call dibs first.
What about you all come to Canada, right?
And then we can do a concert on the East Coast and then on
the West Coast and then somewhere in the middle.
West Coast first.
Actually, no, I think, I don't know.
I think West Coast pretty expensive.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah.
What do you think are some of your biggest like challenges
when it comes to getting a concert together how do you
prepare for something like that it really depends on like
which company you work with too i feel um i think the
biggest challenge is just like um like oh yeah it's just
getting everything done um yeah that's really it's just
getting everything done like like chasing people for stuff
and everything and oh especially if you have like duo songs
getting everybody to do their vocals recording and like like
the checks and balances approving stuff too making sure like
like you have to be very uh proactive when you're approving
something like i want to know what this sounds like i want
to see what that looks like before you yes because like if
you don't they'll just like go and be like checkmark like oh
it's approved but without like you know um without like
proper approvals because they'll like oh it's just a minor
thing but even then i'm very much of a perfectionist so i
was like even if it's a want to be asked about it just in
case i want to change something and you want to see it you
want to know you want to hear it yeah and i think but that's
also really hard for them because like sometimes i'm hard to
reach because i have a hundred million things going on at
the same time and it's very also you stream all the time
yeah traveling you're doing stuff you can't always answer
every two seconds about yeah and it's like everything is
super time sensitive and that's like one of my weaknesses is
just that i tend to like over burden like just overwork
myself or like I take too much I take too much stuff because
I I like I remember me and you both have the same problem we
want we love to say yes to everything because it's like we
don't know we're ever gonna get something like this again
like in there some of that opportunity so that's like and I
always think about the fans too like I want the fans to
experience this I want to give them like how awesome that
you as my fandom get to exactly yeah yeah so it's like I
don't want to say no because I'm like what if in like a year
I won't get offered this ever yeah so it's like I might as
well like if so then that so I can tell people at least I
did it even if I was even if I'm having a mental breakdown
or something at least I did it oh but you know the worst
part is when I've been overburdened and all that stuff
looking back at it I don't remember how stressed and
overburdened I was I just remember how proud I am that I
pulled it off yeah is it the same for you like the end
result unless it's unless we unless like everything goes to
shit like the problem though is like you'll lot of stuff
right and then a lot of projects we both have talked about
this sometimes you get a scope of work and you think okay
even if i overestimate how much work i have to do yeah you
always have to do yeah you always have it would tell you
like there's always this is how much you have to do and then
you get it and this was it was more than that it was that
this was it was it was double that this was not what you
said and it's no one's fault is just oftentimes like things
take longer things get like there might have been delays
someone dropped out or something or something unexpected
happens yeah like it could happen to like like you can't
predict everything basically exactly it's like for not it's
like for a lot of projects so this is like the risk with
projects too because it's just like you know something
something you can't control might happen and like you just
gotta go gg like go next like yeah and and we've talked
about it too where sometimes it's might have a project
that's perfect in your mind but then guess what it's launch
time and you've already delayed and your project isn't over
but you know that okay it's better that i just launched this
like three quarters done project and the worst part is
people don't know that the project isn't done exactly so to
them your fans are so happy to see it while you're watching
it you're thinking oh my god this could have been this is
empty this is empty there were many instances where i had
that were like like something just happened anything comes
to mind uh i'm trying to think of something i could talk
about that comes to yeah yeah without like not not like a
get in trouble way but like maybe like for me for example my
yeah or my oh no no you go first you go first so for my uh
empress matara lore i had to cut a big portion of it out
just because timing wise it was like around when my company
the previous company collapsed yeah so i was just really
tight on resources because a lot of money wasn't getting
paid out a lot of money was held things like that and I
still had to pay staff so a lot of stuff had to get scrapped
and kind of like we had to use images instead it still ended
up being awesome and a lot of my fans love that yeah it's
the trial of evil Momo lore I remember that it's honestly
like half finished and and at that point it was still like a
six-minute lore video and it was only half finished yeah but
it was very well animated even so um i think okay i remember
this is one this one is about like the plushies you remember
the the patch the tiny little dokey plushies so um we had an
instance where uh we got sent uh the first shipment of them
because we sold a lot of them like shout out to my dragons
uh for the mini dokeys um so we were sent like a very small
batch of them just to like uh just to just to have like uh
to be sold at conventions when my distributor received them
i was not happy because i didn't realize they included those
little plush tags thing like those like you know how like
you know washable or like oh the copyright stuff was on on
them but it was on the leg and it was big oh so it like kind
of took over the whole plush sort of like i would say didn't
take over it just didn't look aesthetically pleasing you
know you take pic photos with your little the little
plushies and then there's like this tiny little tag sticking
out i just i was like that doesn't look aesthetically
pleasing like i want to have like cute photos and stuff
where a giant tag isn't so i didn't know that and then i
said why is there a giant tag on the leg and they're like oh
that's like a legal thing like you have it had like legally
when you import plushies in every plush has to have a little
tag on there that says like the the i don't remember exactly
what it has to say but it has to have to have like oh maybe
like washable made in this yeah yeah yeah using this
material basically that like that it has to be on on a
plushie like any fabric thing or it's like considered like
like you can get basically get in trouble with the
government if you don't have that so um so i didn't know
that um because like uh in my head i was just like this this
shit looks so ugly yeah you're like i hate this i do not
want this on my and i was like stop like stop the other
production of the plushies we gotta fix that like stop
everything stop everything we have to i cannot have the
plushies have this ugly ass tag on the leg like anywhere on
the body like that's like it's it's part of the law it's
like you have to have you have to have a tag somewhere so
then from there and then they were like we were
brainstorming because like we're like emergency meaning but
because we don't want to have more plushies being have the
tag sewn in anymore so i was like yeah yeah yeah so i was
like emergency meaning and then we brainstorm and then you
know how on the top like plushies normally at the top
there's like a little loop thing on the top yes where you
can like yeah yeah yeah so So we figured out that to keep it
legal, and we can still import these plushies into Canada.
Oh, I love this.
So we figured out a loophole is what she's saying.
I'm ready.
Give it to me.
A loophole to the law that the government imposed on us on
import imports and exports.
So it doesn't have to be on the plushie.
It can be.
Oh, it can be in the bag.
be no no it could be like you can loop a chain on it and
then have a tag on the chain that you can just remove and
like rip it off so you know how like when you get blankets
you just rip off the tag shit like that yeah okay yeah yeah
i get it but like i didn't want them to rip it off the plush
because like you know people are going to be scared that
they'll break the plush or something so it's like this paper
tag at the metal chain and you could take you know you could
take the chain off remove the tag and then put it back on or
like remove the chain all together so so it won't be on the
plushie so you can have like aesthetically pleasing photos
of the plushie without the ugly i'm trying to find it on
your website i'm trying to find this on your website is it
no longer there wait i can show it i can um it's you can
look i'll show you the photo so i'm pretty sure someone
i can show you i want to see these i'm trying to find i i
didn't want to say i like had a breakdown but i would but
you know if we were not gonna mince words i wasn't very okey
okey i wasn't very happy about i literally was like stop
dokey dokey wasn't feeling very everything we gotta fix this
before we make more of these plushies with this ugly ass tag
on the body but you see i hear i sent you like what we so
you see like there's a metal chain and there's like this
little tag at the bottom or like it's like connected to the
chain and then let me say i could find i need to find a
photo i was like let me see i i look i could let me see if i
could even find like my my replies and how please i'd love
to see yeah just leak your corporate emails to me we would
love to that's a bull next next On Patreon, we get drunk and
we read all your corporate complaints and emails.
Let's do it.
That's bullshit.
I do not want wash tags.
It is ugly.
Let's see.
I refuse to sell the plushies with the wash tag.
Okay, wait, wait, just I need to know to be clear.
You send that to like your manager, right?
I send my manager.
And then I was like, I've said worse things to my manager.
i refuse i will refund everybody if this goes through like i
was i was willing to take that step because i thought it was
so i was legitimately i was like this is ugly and then it's
funny looking back then i i'm gonna send you the photo and
you're like i had a breakdown over this i it wasn't even
that bad i'm excited show me show me show me it's bad i just
don't okay i'll be honest with not amazing but I agree it is
a funny breakdown to have over that and I need to validate
you by the way this is so normal if anybody is listening and
you're a streamer sometimes you work so hard on a project
and like you get like something back from a company and
they're like do you like this and it's like I don't know
maybe a website and none of the pixels align nothing and
you're sitting there and you're like what the fuck am I
looking at you know obviously you would never say that to
i'm sorry um you know your manager will politely my manager
will politely open the brief like they'll do like pr they'll
do pr translate to me like i say like everything in my heart
and then they'll pr translate it yeah make it sound nice and
they'll politely say like hey you know we just feel that we
we gave you guys a direction and feel like it hasn't been
respected would you guys please do us the favor and then i
think that is my message to my manager would be like this is
fucking ugly i need them to change this right now or i'm
gonna freak out and
but like the like like because like i'm such a perfectionist
so it's like like little things like that because i know
like if i take photos of it and it has that wash it's just
not gonna look nice so i'm like in my eyes like i want this
to be something that people are happy about like overall and
then like these like these i have like these tiny things too
that i like to control too because it's like like one tiny
thing makes a huge difference because you can see how it
really does how if i didn't stop them um also like we did
have a lot of these already done and i was like just cut it
like yeah yeah yeah i just the tag and then we'll loop the
other tag on there because like obviously we can't
technically we can't sell like if it got cut before we sold
them yeah yeah but you can loop the other tag I do want to
know like obviously you know we're talking about this so
dramatically and so but this is such a normal thing and I
think as a creator you being so aware of your brand and what
you're giving your audience is so important I I wish more
content creators did that I wish more brands did that you
know it happens sometimes where things get delayed and for
example we don't even get told so for me if I find out from
my audience that things are delayed and the company didn't
tell me I instantly or kind of go there and be like, what's
happening?
What do you mean there's delays?
Like, I think it is so, so, so good that you're so, like,
you know, I want to use the word anal about it, but I don't
know what other synonym I can use.
It's good that you're so like on top of it.
Yeah, like, I can see people be like, oh, she's like too
picky or like, she might be like a bit too, like, you know,
I don't know, too.
Only the best merch for your Dragoons.
Only the best.
All I would do is just want the best for people.
Like, want the best for my audience because they support us
and they like worked so hard to like support us and
everything you know and you don't want them to get an item
that isn't top yeah and i want to you know this is like my
like i'm wanting to my gift to them as well like i want i
take care of them they take care of me having previously
been in in a now defunct company where i you know at the
beginning trusted a lot wait no not samsy right no different
different but i thought you're like and like um no it was
the different one and uh where you know i kind of of let
them go ahead and like do some merch and then later i
received some of these items and i said this does not pass
my quality check this does not pass my quality check this
doesn't pass my quality check i want to get more involved
and then i got more involved with the merch yeah and then we
found out some merch wasn't shipping for a year and a half
yeah yeah good times but i think it's always really really
good as a creator to get like more you know be more hands-on
about it if you have problems ask for things to change ask
for things to improve because you're you know you're giving
these to your audience and they deserve the best exactly
like that that's why i like like i know like a lot some
people not a lot but like some people they like to like just
uh delegate it to other people i i'm trying to delegate like
i still try to delegate because obviously i'm one person
can't do everything um but there are like some instances
where i have to be like part of the process and like every
step of the way like i i know like sometimes it sounds like
you don't have to be part of this and it's like no i have i
really need to like like be able to like be part of this
process and just like have it be my the vision that i have
in my head yeah my baby i do wonder if some of it is coming
you know you had mentioned like our other job but like i
wonder if some of it comes from not having been giving
freedom before so now that we have the freedom and we have
the independence and we have the audience that supports us i
want to know like what they're getting i want to know the
image you know i want to kind of like be there every step of
the way opportunity to have like fun creative stuff too i
never had fun no i meant like no i you know like the the
more like you can do what you can make whatever you want
type feel like that's the freedom that you're given as an
indie like you can make whatever you want to make and like
i's like possibilities are endless and i fucked up and make
dog shirts and i love your dog shirts by the way and i made
like i was given too much sometimes sometimes you shouldn't
be given too much freedom because i have i disagree no no i
you don't we have so many boxes of dog shirts we've okay
okay idea hear me out hear me out hear me out find some kind
of like next time at events try to do some kind of like no i
guess dog fights are not legal but like dog walking events
no we've been selling no the thing is it's um we sell them
at conventions and it's been working because like dog shirts
work yeah dog shirts work because it's not like universally
it's not tied to a vtuber technically so like you know
people have dogs and then they're like i should get a dog
shirt for my dog and it's a shirt that's like it has like
yeah and then it's a hot dog shirt it's so it's pretty silly
it's like hawaiian hot dog shirt so it's like i love it so
we're able to sell a lot of them and we still have a lot of
them but we were able to sell a lot if i had a dog i'd buy
two of these for my dog and i'd make i make them for both i
mean you can buy two dog shirts and then sew it together to
make one big dog shirt for me no for your for your i don't
know for your future dog are you are you calling me a no no
buy it my buy a dog buy two dog shirts in advance just in
case uh yeah yeah for for your future dog you know what
maybe buy one effort when your child starts growing exactly
couldn't you put children in the dog the child in the dog
but he just needs like it that obviously it's gonna have a
really it's like a little tuxedo you know like those long
penguin tuxedos dokey dokey dokey dokey release a dragoon
plush that would fit into that shirt like like a long you
know because you have a dragoon that has like the long neck
and then like build a bear and then yeah build a bear plus
she's like yeah you need a shirt for your build a goon build
a goon like literally release the kind of shirt i'm saying
that idea actually release the kind of sorry the do it i'm
telling you right now release the long dragoon yeah that
would fit into that shirt and literally be like hey if you
buy the dragoon and the shirt the shirt will be a little bit
off yeah yeah it's like a bundle exactly exactly oh you're
you're you're you're capitalism i like your capitalism right
now capitalism oh my god she's capillising right now guys i
am i am you're welcome no because i was looking at the shirt
and i was like what if you put a plushie in that was my that
i'm like said that idea before too they're like they make a
plushie for them to wear as well it's yeah but all the idea
was from from matara but then on the description i'll be
like the idea i came up with it significantly has to be the
long neck dragoon because the way the shirt is like you kind
of need to have their little arms and then the bottom like
literally do that do that right now i'll write that down
i'll write that down right now when she releases it come
back to the comments my birthday merch would be released by
oh my gosh wait i'll show you what what my birthday merch is
because it's released when this podcast comes out anyway i'm
excited um and i will i will give a link to dokey merch and
we're gonna talk about it go to dokey merch get your dokey
bird merch everybody please take a look at the dokey bird
hot dog pet shirt let me see if i could find it oh wait here
it is dress your pup in peak cuteness with a dokey bird dog
t-shirt a vibrant button-up pet shirt featuring an all-over
print of dokey as a hot dog look at this this is the
birthday merch
Stop.
That's so cute.
You know the boxers though?
The I love it.
I love it.
I have a version of it where the face is on the it basically
is a set of two.
So you can you can have the face either on your crotch or on
your butt.
I love it.
What is that?
Is that a towel?
I can't tell.
Or is that a peepee pad?
It's a little like it's a sleepy blanket.
That's so cute.
I cannot wait to see this.
I love like boxers.
I think that's a great, great job.
I've always, it's like, I've been wanting to make this for
like, I think a year and a half.
Like I drew a concept art of this a long time ago and I
joked about it on stream.
Let me see if I could find it.
And of course that's the worst part about these kinds of
jokes is people love it.
Also your birthday bundle says 2027.
Oh, does it?
No, it's not.
Yeah.
Okay, just for funsies though, I will, for my editor, I will
use this photo because I think it's funny and just letting
you know it's coming out in a few days and you have the
wrong date.
It came out like a few days ago.
Like what we would have is fixed.
Listen, Doki.
Yeah.
Hey, girl, I got you on the Doki Pup shirt thing.
I got you on here.
Run your stuff by me.
I got you, girl.
That's my, I will use this image though.
That's my hag right there.
That's my hag.
I can math, hag can math.
I need to find I can I can do what I need to find all right
tell your editor to pause while I try to find this picture
not going to be anti-climatic at all guys we found it we
devolve into meowing I found it this was the original all
right I just the original concept art
this is what I said to them and then yeah and this is this
is a version where the ass that the face is on the ass by
the way I am gonna give you a deep cut this reminded me in
in another life many many years ago where I showed you my
folder of me drawing Pokemon on MS3.
I was like, I was like, you reacted the way I'm reacting
now.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
I was just like, you were like, what flavor of autism is
this, Matara?
Like, I don't understand what you mean.
You drew these awful pixel art Pokemon on MS3.
Like, just randomly.
This is beautiful.
Oh, yeah.
I love this also like by the way everybody she's an artist
like she actually is an you can you can't tell though from
that you can it's a little hard to tell but like but you
know what like it makes sense yeah i get it i get the vision
yeah and then you give it no i get it and then and you know
and you know how work how it's inspired by this is because a
long time ago what is that crane game um that you can play
online uh i'm trying to remember a crane game but i think i
know what you mean where people were like streaming it and
like doing right toroba right toroba yeah so okay it was a
long time ago and i was playing toroba on stream and then
one of the items was a my melody boxer short and i was like
guys i have to get this and like i'm assuming right so i
have to use advantage I can get.
So I was like, of course I was like, dragoons, all of you
make it as close as you can get and then leave.
And now I'll come back and I'll, oh, I love that.
Is that medigaming?
Yeah, I was medigaming.
It was like, yeah, I was just like, guys, guys, we all want
me to have this, right?
How badly do you want me to have this?
So I was like, guys, help me get this as close as you can so
that I can come in and snipe it.
at the end you know i think i could i think i could do more
i think i could i think i can be worse how worse i like that
no this is great i've never thought of like utilizing my
audience in that way that's so smart because they're
obviously better than me at the crane game like yeah they're
obviously you could be like look we all want me to be happy
right we all want we all want me to have this funny post you
know like anyway this was what it looks like too and because
i was like i want to see my the face is on the ass by the
way the face i'm ready i said it i sent it oh wait that's
actually really yeah yeah but i thought it was like a my
that's actually really really boxer shorts and i was like i
have like everyone's like you have to have this jokie i was
like how bad do you want me to have this did you spend a lot
of money to be honest it was so long ago i like i've i've
i've i've had a lot i've done i've won a lot of stupid on
toroba just because i thought it was just funny like um it's
like such a funny flex but not flex of like i've won a lot
of shit yeah just like you know because you know i love shit
posting so i just like i don't like i like i'm not doing
toroba for like things that i think is like i like you know
be like oh it's cute or oh this looks like look look at this
expensive figure or something i was just like that looks
funny i want it i have a cat robot like those like little
cat butler robots you know but it's like a miniature size of
that that i want on actually bring you anything or not
really it's like those like you know like in japan they had
these like mini cat robots that bring you stuff at
restaurants like in i've only well they're not mini they're
like they're big they're like the size of a child right but
they have a miniature size of that that you can yeah and
then it was on tour of and i was just like i had to have it
like i no i get it i get it like sometimes it's it's like no
no i don't care what it is i just oh my god wait so you yeah
i know exactly what you're talking about a tiny miniature
size of that that can bring you like tiny things can you
actually put anything on it or will it kind of since it's so
tiny i worry like will a coffee or something spill that's a
good question i've never done that before i've done like
bottled stuff try it like literally experiment i think you
should do an experiment where it's like what can i put on
that will that would fall can i do a champagne like can I do
this can I do that like a stress test basically yeah but do
it before your house cuz that way you know sometimes I feel
guilty I pre clean my house before my I do that I throw
trash away before my cleaner comes because I want them to
clean not like throw trash so like you know I'm trying to
make sure there's space for them to clean exactly exactly
Doki this was a pleasure I I will be honest I didn't even
ask you half the I didn't even realize it was over.
I shared some questions.
I know, hey, don't worry.
We are going to grab, I need to pee after this, so we are
going to grab a drink and get a little spicy on the Patreon.
Check out the Patreon.
Unfiltered, uncensored.
Before we go, I want you to advertise yourself.
Is there anything that's coming out, anything you want to
talk about?
We're going to be posting Doki merch.
Anything else you want to talk about?
Anything else you want to promote?
Well, obviously, hashtag buy my merch, guys.
We have the birthday bundle out right now.
out guys subscribe to me on youtube gonna try and get
million subscribers um so soon for you too and i i don't
know i don't know if i'm gonna get it this year i think
maybe next year because like to be fair this year i've been
mostly i've been doing a lot of like outside like i guess
like traveling a lot this year's my traveling year i think
oh yeah it is also at the at the rate that you go viral you
just need like two more dokey viral moments that you that's
true like it comes so easy for me it does it does the metals
the virality yeah just just go viral you know it's just that
easy just go viral just go viral just go viral forehead come
on just just just just just do that let's go viral what else
is there to have test oh we have our streaming vods our vods
for and I can check out as well from our 3D concert.
And there's going to be some pay-per-view tickets, which I'm
going to be posting the links to Doki.
Thank you so much for joining me on my second ever episode.
I will have to have you on again because I didn't even ask
you half the stuff I wanted to talk to you about.
She gave me a list and I was like, whoa, that's a lot of
questions.
And I think we got like two questions.
But hey, you know what?
Now I did my work for next time.
Yeah, let's just have to do work next time.
Bye, guys.
drink let's go drink on the patreon what if i don't want to
leave come on all right bye i gotta bye everybody bye guys
bye guys there are
people who rise with the sun people who answer their calls
at 11 who make their noon appointments and those who know
with certainty what day it is i matara khan am not one of
those people because i have found something better room
service nothing fancy just a little drink in the evening and
apparently again in the morning too that 11 o'clock call
went a voicemail stream has been pushed back brunches at
this time a rumor in the wind gamer subs room service for
the dedicated sleepers